mein thema heute abend ist nämlich
russland darauf den europäischen
gerichtshof für menschenrechte russland
wurde nämlich aus dem europarat
ausgeschlossen
145 millionen russland russen sind die
leidtragenden in bleibt der zugang zum
europäischen gerichtshof für
menschenrechte künftig verwehrt der
grund der zugang zu diesem gericht ist
ein die mitgliedschaft im europarat
verbunden hier muss man wissen aus
russland stammen mit abstand die meisten
klagen am europäischen gerichtshof für
menschenrechte
oft ist dieser die letzte hoffnung für
justizopfer die nzz ist eins der
menschenrechtsgerichtshof ist der
stachel im fleisch der russischen justiz
hoffen wir dass es bald wieder sein kann
auch wenn russland die urteile des
menschenrechtsgerichts hof in der
vergangenheit nicht wirklich ernst
genommen hat waren sie immer doch ein
signal an russland auch an die menschen
vor ort wir hören hin wir sehen euch
aber natürlich weiß ich dass es richtig
war russland aus dem europarat
auszuschließen und damit leider auch aus
dem menschengerichtshof ich möchte
trotzdem heute die debatte darüber
führen wie man vielleicht dennoch etwas
für die russische bevölkerung möglich
machen könnte und da würde ich direkt
ein paar ronzheimer in kiew weitergeben
was er zu meiner these denkt
also ich denke zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
hilft in jederlei hinsicht nur härte und
der ausschluss ist vollkommen
gerechtfertigt hätte aus meiner sicht
schon viel früher passieren müssen und
in wahrheit sind wir da bei der frage
die wir schon vorhin diskutiert haben
inwieweit ist sozusagen eine gesamte
bevölkerung ich will nicht sagen haftbar
aber mitverantwortlich oder
verantwortlich für das was die regierung
tut und da bin ich doch der meinung dass
viele menschen offenbar dort nicht
verstanden haben was in der ukraine
passiert noch einmal es werden jeden tag
hunderte bomben auf dieses land
von putin fallengelassen raketen
abgefeuert und jeden tag sterben
unschuldige menschen und wir haben heute
gesehen diese jubel arie für wladimir
putin wir sehen umfragewerte wo die
bevölkerung weiterhin an ihn glaubt und
sagt hier in der ukraine wo ich bin sind
gerade nach also ich glaube wir müssen
und da gehört die frage dazu die duh
diskutiert hast in jederlei hinsicht
deutlich machen dass das was wladimir
putin tut
dass das verbrecherisch ist und leider
gottes gehören solche maßnahmen dazu
naja ich bin da etwas zwiegespalten es
ist im wesentlichen ja einen gesprächs
gremium russland ist da schon einmal
suspendiert worden nach der krim aktion
interessanterweise ist dann auf drängen
russlands hinterher ein passus eingefügt
worden in die statuten dass eine
suspendierung nicht mehr möglich ist
jetzt kann man eigentlich nur noch raus
werfen und nichts anderes andererseits
muss man eben auch sagen der europäische
gerichtshof für menschenrechte ist
eigentlich im grunde genommen die letzte
hoffnung die einen regimekritiker in
russland noch haben kann soweit ich
gehört habe hat russland sogar eine
entschädigungssumme an navalny gezahlt
ich weiß nicht ob das stimmt es wird
auch nicht viel gewesen sein
insofern ist es immer schwierig wir
haben ja auch den un-menschenrechtsrat
wohl so ziemlich alle schurken dieser
welt mit drin sitzen zum teil schwer
schwere frauen rechtsverletzer im
gleichstellungs komitee das ist alles
ein bisschen zum teil widersinnig
andererseits muss man sagen okay wenn
man irgendetwas damit bewegen kann dann
sollte man es versuchen die vereinten
nationen sind ja auch ein klub der nicht
irgendjemanden ausschließt sonst müsste
man eigentlich russland rauswerfen wird
wahrscheinlich nicht passieren aber dann
könnte es ja selbst veto einlegen ich
bin immer ein bisschen im zweifel auch
sinn und nutzen von symbolischen gesten
da einem guten verhältnis stehen die
ächtung des russischen krieges ist
glaube ich auf allen ebenen von den
vereinten nationen bis runter nach
europa und in einzelne nationen bis
jetzt deutlich geworden wenn es irgend
etwas helfen kann wäre ich dafür
russland zumindest weiter dem
europäischen gerichtshof zu unterstellen
ob das lässt sich jetzt glaube ich aber
nicht mehr reparieren insofern ist es
verschüttete milch
der ruf sanktion mit voller härte würde
ich immer ein stimmen aber die frage ist
ja ob der ausschluss aus diesen
europäischen gerichtshof jetzt putin und
seine freunde trifft oder ob sie nicht
vielleicht sogar froh sind dass sie das
los sind weil jeder sowieso suspekt war
als instanz und dass er anderen geholfen
hat also ich meine es stimmt schon es
ist passiert und es wird vielleicht
nicht mehr zurückzuholen seien aber die
frage sehr gibt es nochmal sanktionen
die die viel zielgerichteter treffen
also luxusyachten der oligarchischen
beschlagnahme zuschauen bei den
immobilien wenn den der hand von seinem
putins freunden sind kann man dort nicht
stärker eingehen ich weiß dass es
verdammt schwierig das nachzuweisen dass
die wirklich die inhaberin gerichtet
auch die sanktion zu verteilen ist
natürlich auch nicht so eine arbeit zum
beispiel dort wo wir in zugriff hätten
auf luxus jahren oder immobilien dies in
hier in europa gibt es für die
beschlagnahme das ist dass die
fiskalische forensik hochproblematisch
nachzuweisen weil die sind ja geschickt
und schicken dann oft mittelsmänner vor
aber das wäre nochmal ansetzt wo ich
sagen würde darunter leitet kein
einziger menschenrechtsaktivistin
russland aber es könnte ihn und sein
umfeld viel stärker treffen wir sind ja
als rechtsstaaten leider immer etwas
unschönen situation das ganze
legalisieren zu müssen kann ja nicht
einfach zu sagen du hast doch damals mit
putin gekuschelt jetzt aber aus das
macht alles immer etwas schwieriger aber
es ist ja der wohlmöglich listen zu
benennen es gibt ja auch für die
playoffs für audio weisung gibt es ja
auch eine liste der unerwünschten person
stand und und bei den immobilien steht
meistens allerdings nicht in ihr boot
ihn im grundbuch und auch bei den grafen
sind irgendwelche schon eingetragen das
macht es also für uns immer etwas
schwieriger auch wenn jeder weiß dass es
dem imperium zuzuordnen ist es ist bei
uns meistens schwieriger neue solche
leute zu verfolgen und auch sippenhaft
ist ja bei uns nicht wirklich
gang und gäbe also auch angehörige zu
belangen da tun sich auch rechtsstaaten
dann immer schwer ich will dass damit
jetzt nicht recht nicht rechtfertigen
das problem ist einfach wenn wir uns an
unsere eigenen hohen standards halten
sind uns die hände öfter gebunden als
ein willkür herrscher wie putin
paul an dieser stelle nochmals zu dir
nach kehrst du verbringst auch viel zeit
mit den klitschko-brüdern mit dem
bürgermeister von kiew vitali klitschko
was fordern die klitschko-brüder was
fordern die menschen in der ukraine was
wir tun können
ja ich komme tatsächlich gerade von ihm
und habe mit ihm ein interview geführt
beziehungsweise war dort das ist eine
immer noch absurde szenerie die beiden
brüder immer zusammen man muss wissen
vor war es so dass vitali seinen job als
bürgermeister hatte und wladimir ist
sozusagen zwischen hamburg zwischen usa
und kiew hin und her gewandert jetzt
sieht man sie an verschiedenen orten
immer geheimen orten natürlich immer
zusammen irgendwie rührend auch zu sehen
die beiden wie sie sich unterstützen
aber häufig auch in voller kampfmontur
sozusagen also zumindest mit
schutzwesten
sind dann dort vor den häusern die
völlig zerstört sind und man sieht ihnen
an wie sehr ihn das wie sehr sie das
mitnimmt zusehen wie ihre heimatstadt
hier nach und nach weiter kaputt gepumpt
wird
also das wird also dass das sieht man
wirklich im gesicht von tag zu tag wie
sehr die beiden das zeichnet was
deutschland angeht da fragen sie mich
immer wie bestimmte dinge wie das
eigentlich sein kann also da ging es
auch um die debatte tatsächlich die wir
hier schon geführt haben nämlich olaf
scholz hat ja auch in einem tweet klar
gemacht dass das alles nur
ausschließlich putins krieg sei und man
sozusagen da nicht die russen insgesamt
kritisieren solle und das sieht man hier
in kiew sehr an dass man sagt ja wo sind
denn diejenigen die sich wirklich
distanzieren wo ist denn die welle der
solidarität mit der ukraine das ist das
eine das zweite was sie sehr sehr ärgert
ist die deutsche zurückhaltung weiterhin
bei den sanktionen da gibt es ja auch
berichte dass deutschland wieder dafür
verantwortlich ist dass bestimmte
sanktion nicht umgesetzt wurden damit
meine ich jetzt nicht öl- und
gas-embargo sondern auch einzelne
weitere und dann wieder für ausnahmen
gesorgt hat die skepsis ist groß was
deutschland angeht in der ukraine das
muss man ganz klar sagen und das hat vor
allem mit den letzten jahren zu tun und
immer wieder mit den aussagen nord
stream zwei die gaspipeline das hat
nichts mit putin zu tun also die
unmenschen offenheit und die putin liebe
vieler politiker lange zeit die sorgt
sie dafür dass man doch sehr skeptisch
nach deutschland schaut